hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com so for those who
don't know me yet i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong on the option
market and i've just started guys to
make some youtube videos because i want
to show you
how pro traders actually working what
kind of tools and techniques
we use and especially how we analyze the
data because this is what we do
every day and after analyzing this data
we can build up a review and take our
positions
so in this video i want to show you how
i compute the synthetic shot on gamestop
which i did already
but most importantly guys i want to show
you something crazy i want to show you
how to predict what is the level where
the next
shoot quiz will happen let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so very quickly uh for
those who have not
watched what i did before i'm using the
open interest that is available on
yahoo finance i compute for every strike
the synthetic notional that i have here
the synthetic exposure sorry which is
the notional
time the delta and to compute the delta
i'll
i just use this formula i guess that you
can find on the internet that is the
black schultz formula
so that is using the normal distribution
n
and you need to compute d1 which is
basically equal to this formula where
you
only need to know the strike the spot
price the volatility and the maturity
volatility is in percentage maturity is
in years so i did it guys like you can
see for
all the maturities you see that
are actually listed uh all of them guys
so it took me hours it took me a
very long time to do that but i think
it's very interesting to get this exact
precise information and for every strike
i do delta times the open interest
and i multiply this by 100 and by the
spot price
as you can see here this is the formula
let me put it here
so the delta times the open interest
times 100 100 is the multiplier that you
have on
every u.s stock for all the option
market in the united states
times the spot all right i did that i
come up with 1 billion
so this is and i only use cool options
before in my first video i was using put
options and collapsions because you know
it was taking a lot of time to make the
difference i was making some
approximations
and i came up with a different number
this number is correct
so as a percentage of the current market
cap we have eight percent
guys of short interest all right first
information i'm not going to show you
how the gamma is working for now
what i'm going to show you guys is where
we're going to have the first squeeze to
do that
guys i uh go on the chart of
gamestop here it is this is all my
drawings i'm not going to go through
this here and i check the first squeeze
the first quiz happened on
22nd of jan you can see this huge volume
traded
20 billion usd were trading that day
it's absolutely huge it's insane
and what was the level on 22nd of jan
the level
was around 70 already started at 50 so
between 50 and 75 so let's call this
65 when we were at 65
a short squeeze happened okay first
information
now i'm gonna show you guys something
amazing you're gonna love it
what was the short interest at that time
easy to find because this is public
information
so once again you can say this data is
not correct i believe
it is correct you know it is just going
lower which is actually making sense if
it was actually bigger
it would remain stable and slowly hedge
funds would declare the true short
positions
but this number is going lower which is
telling me that this is correct
anyway on the 22nd of jan the short
interest was 120
123 all right so now
we are gonna try to find what level is
going to make 120
short interest as a percentage of that
market cap not today's market cap
right so this is the difference you know
uh between what i was doing before and
what i'm going to show you
now here when i compute this percentage
of
its percentage of the current market cap
right and if gamestop goes higher
and before in my first video i was
leaving this
at 10 billion all right because it's
interesting to compare it to the current
market cap
uh let's say 10 billion usd but actually
what is more interesting is to compute
this percentage of short interest as a
percentage of
the market cap we had when we had the
first squeeze because we know
that it happens at 120 so let's do that
let's consider that the market cap is
equal to 65
i do this you see equals 65 times the
outstanding number of shares so
basically i'm having the same market cap
and as a percentage of that market cap
now we are at 20
we know that we have already 20 of
natural
short interest so basically we want to
reach 100 now if i go to
400 all right so this is the gamma guys
this is the gamma kicking in
because you can see guys the crazy
amount of collapsions that you have on
the upside
for gamestop once again guys for apple
it looks like this all right
this is apple and you can see that the
gamma is located around the money
for amc you have a bit of gamma here a
lot of gamma around the money and for
gamestop you
you have a crazy amount of gamma at the
800 strike
which makes this stock a very potential
stock
for a short squeeze a gamma squeeze all
right and now guys when we are
at 4 15 you can see that we already have
this short interest as a percentage of
the market cap
we had for the first shot squeeze that
is 130
what is this telling us guys and you
have 20 on top of that all right
i should add here the 20 that we have
right now
so i would be at 150 short interest
compared to the old market cap so even
before that
so around 400 guys so if we go to 400
we will be in the exact same situation
in terms of
risk in terms of loss that we
used to be when the first short squeeze
happened
so once again i'm not saying here that
this is gonna happen for sure
i'm just showing you that the same
conditions
would be here again the same exact
situation
would happen again if we go to 400
because of this synthetic short that is
very concentrated on the upside
this is going to create some gamma on
the upside
so what we only need guys for this
scenario to happen
is a sparkle because if gamestop stays
at 200
once again guys we are compared to the
previous market cap around 50
of short interest all right and it's not
enough
for the hedge funds to stop the position
for the market makers to buy
shares at a crazy price whatever the
price is actually
so that's it for me i hope i managed to
show you guys how to use the
financial data that we can find on the
internet and
to compute some other data and to
compare it
with past events because this is what is
technical analysis guys is to
actually consider that the past is going
to reproduce itself
if the same conditions are reunited
again
and if you did enjoy this video please
guys don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys